hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts validation of mass spec
analytical platform and proteomic
biomarkers FDA perspective presented by
dr. Doug Jeffrey we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab root for more
information please visit labrys com my
name is soon fans and I'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentations just click on the green
Q&A button located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears from
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing for presentations in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the two and I button until itís
know that you're having a problem now
I'd like to introduce dr. Jeffrey
trajectory received his Bachelor science
degree in biology from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology event received
his PhD in biochemistry from the
University of California San Francisco
afterwards he joined the Novartis
Institute of metafile medical research
where you perform basic research in
oncology target discovery dr. Jeffrey is
currently assigned to the reviewer at
the Food and Drug Administration Center
for Devices and Radiological health
please join me in welcoming dr. Jeffrey
I will now turn the presentation over to
him great thank you John for the
introduction and thank you to lab roots
for giving the opportunity to talk about
mass spectrometry and clinical and
dietro Diagnostics so here at the
outline of my talk is here i'm going to
start the first part of the talk and
discuss
the role that FDA plays in the
regulation of in vitro diagnostics and
then in the middle part of the talk
discuss our experience directly with
mass spectrometry and loose of mass
spectrometry in vitro diagnostics and
then talk a little bit about the end
specifically about protein and peptide
identification and quantitation using
mass spectrometry so this is the overall
organization of the Food and Drug
Administration I am in the center for
diagnostics and Radiological health and
specifically in the opposite in vitro
diagnostics and Radiological health we
are one of seven centers within the FDA
some of you may have heard of cedar or
know about cedar cedar is the center
that regulates and of quiz or proves
most of the new drugs that are marketed
in the United States are rolling in
cedar etching in lr in particular is to
regulating improve or clear in vitro
diagnostics they're used to diagnose the
news the just to start out is very
broadly the definition I'm going to eat
your diagnostic according to the Food
Drug and Cosmetic Act is an instrument
well this is the definition of a medical
device is an instrument apparatus in
that machine Travis implant or in vitro
reagent that it intended for use in the
diagnosis of disease or other conditions
in particular our role is to regulate
noir's regularly in vitro religions that
are intended for use in diagnosis of
disease early conditions and what that
means is that we regulate medical
devices that measure that are used to
measure anything which is taken from the
body so that's the in contrast to things
like stamps or hip implants which are
actually implanted in the body those are
regulated by a different office within
the center spirit or not been put in CDR
hme regulate only those literally agents
and be trip diagnostics the way that we
reviewed vitro diagnostic submission to
in fact
all submissions is that line here the
most important one most important parts
of a submission for news betray
diagnostic is defining intended use
Luther essentially describes how the ivd
is meant to be used for screening for
for illegal population for prognosis or
other things which will go into later
the other important thing is to
understand what patient population is
meant to be tested with this device for
example its patients that have or
suspected to have rheumatoid arthritis
or patients that are undergoing
mandeville treatment for particularly
reason and the mighty d might be used to
decide which treatment they get the
intended use defines what we call the
risk of the device in the risk is three
classes of risk from low to high risk
and the risk of the device in turn
defines which type of submission that is
required at the FDA to give clearance or
approval for marketing of that device in
the United States there are the two
major types of device at PMA to
premarket approvals for highest risk
last three devices and then moderate
risk for class two devices are clear the
510k process we'll talk more about this
in a minute just to emphasize those and
we'll talk about this in more detail of
classification either class 1 2 or 3
determines the scope of the studies that
are necessary to demonstrate the
performance of the device both the
analytical and the clinical performance
what's not shown up above but is
important and this would be the only
time I mentioned it is using a device or
measuring particular biomarker and
clinical trial may require what's called
an IDE or investigational device
exemption and so if you were if anyone
is interested or foods to use an IV Dior
or particularly in clinical trial you
would need to contact the FDA and then
they should be I new process r actually
the what's underlined here and we'll
talk about this at the end is the
pre-submission process so this is
something that
accessible to anyone and it's basically
an opportunity for a device developers
device manufacturers to submit questions
submitted description on your device and
questions tsk to help guide your your
developer development by some more
pocket more detail about that at the end
of the top so one of the key things that
we are we regulate or we're interested
in understanding about devices is the
safety and effectiveness and what do we
mean by safety and effectiveness this is
sort of a broad brush look at it but
there are two main components of safety
of the device one is how accurate are
the results of the test with for
measuring particular analyte is a serum
or plasma the analytical performance
needs to be tested and studies foods to
perform to look at for instance the
accuracy of advice in the linearity the
precision reproducibility device' me
evaluate the analytical performance to
determine whether the device actually is
able to measure reproducibly in well
leanna like that it's intended to
measure the other really important piece
of safety is is what is the risk to the
patient of a false positive and false a
negative result basically what happens
if the test is wrong what's the
potential outcome in terms of the
patient's health or safety two simple
examples of this are you know an amino
acid that measures really factor could
be used it often used as a in the
diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis in
conjunction with other symptoms or
patient histories so in that case that
the moderate this device in the sense
that if that device were if the result
were wrong there is other information
that the position in the patient are
easy to determine whether the patient
has been detroit arthritis and what a
potential course of treatment might be
in contrast a high-risk device such as
one which is intended to determine what
treatment a patient with for instance
cancer might yet if that device were to
be wrong that that patient might not get
potentially life-saving learn like
prolonging medication or alternatively a
patient might get medication that they
don't need and that might have
significant
sexin consequences for their health so
the risk to the patient about false
result is something that we take that we
consider them seriously the
effectiveness part is basically asked
questions a touch irrelevant to the
criminal clinical condition this is done
by performing clinical studies and
looking the clinical performance of the
device so as I said the before the risk
classification either class 1 2 or 3
determine to type of submission that's
required so on the left-hand side you
can see class two devices required some
class 1 devices requirements called a
510 K premarket notification and then
class 3 devices call it require
submission which is called the
pre-market approval and both of these
Commission's are required before device
manufacturer developer can market the
drug in line with market the device in
the United States there are some pretty
significant differences between these
tools you can imagine a class 3
high-risk device requires more clinical
more more evidence more valid sites
examines it will also always requires
clinical data requires a lengthy review
process including in fashion extensive
inspections whereas a 510 K device is is
cleared by comparison to existing
predicate device so there are many
that's take an example amino acids in
many Indian ah seeds that have been
cleared already in are marketed to
measure something like they're in a
choice factor for elite arthritis and so
a new device that measures in the tech
factor would then be compared to a
meeting laughter and a device that that
already measures that that analyte and
the performance of that device has to be
equivalent to the predicate device the
platen Cape submission is a little bit
shorter there is a manufacturing view
and ending the requirements to get
marketing approval are somewhat less
than for a PMA so I want to talk a
little bit about intended use this is
very important thing that we which which
defines the risk of the device as I
mentioned before there are a lot of
different
so broad intended uses that are
described here not going to differ
Albans sort of talk generally about
screening and diagnosis so a screening
intended use would would be ones that
every day even such as music patients
that have no signs or symptoms so that
I've seen otherwise normal their
diagnostic intended use would be
enabling diagnosis of patients who
already have signs and symptoms for
instance the different uses of different
intended uses types intended users have
potentially different in this
determination classifications so for
instance of class a screening device
would potentially be class three because
you're talking about normal subjects
what people who are otherwise healthy
and if the test is wrong you might miss
those people who actually have the DS or
patients you don't have the season and
they might get some unnecessary
treatments a diagnostic claim is the
class to request weeks potentially in
the keep using the rheumatoid arthritis
example where a rheumatoid factor test
would be using patients you already have
already have signs and symptoms of
rheumatoid arthritis and the risk there
is of course that if you if the test is
wrong you might not treat them
appropriately and if the test is or you
might give them treatments that they
don't necessarily need an important
thing for consideration of intended uses
is defining the population of patients
like I've talked about it via their
beginning and so in this example for
ever thinking about this very generally
screening device which is meant to be
tested in both normal healthy population
would require that type of patient in
their clinical studies that are being
done this could be done in Omaha we
population that it says this cruise ease
for example healthy a lung cancer
screening test might be used in patients
of a certain age you history of smoking
but
healthy own have no symptoms a
diagnostic intended use for these
patients who already have the signs and
symptoms if so it's very important it is
not that these plays are not going to
normal population but rather patients in
case of rheumatoid arthritis you have
some joint pain on or difficulty or here
will basically joint pain so in terms of
the analytical studies that are required
for 510 caves there are a number of
different sources of information for
designing studies going to talk really
in terms of the vm the way these these
sorts of information are used actually
in the development of tests and the kind
of tests that we require in submissions
so i'm not going to talk too much about
the column on the left which is the IC h
which is is mostly for drugs and
biologics but the two that are so
important for a neutral diagnostics are
Clea NLCS I so the CLIA regulations are
part of the Center for Medicaid in my
medicare and medicaid services are
intended mostly for clinical labs and
ensure the proper training the lab
personnel performance of the assays
again the clsi documents are something
which FDA and we exceed eh recognized as
important guidelines for the development
of iBD's their intended both for
clinical labs and device manufacturers
and it provides an excellent some of
them the ones that we recognize provide
an excellent source of information for
study design and data analysis to be
used for the analytical validation of ib
use and the clsi documents that we
recognize at cdh are all there were
publicly on the coh website right i
think i talked about that so
one of the things that questions that we
often get particularly about analytical
validation of electro diagnostic devices
and terminal performances questions
about the acceptance criteria and how
does the device developer know what
acceptance criteria are okay so a
particular device so it's simple example
acceptance criteria would be when
looking at the precision stability of
the device what's what's a an acceptable
percent coefficient variation in percent
TV when measuring the same sample over
and over again and there are acceptance
criteria for from all of the analytical
performance test things that is done
that's just one example so the challenge
here is that the acceptance criteria and
study design depend on the type of the
device the technology behind the device
and also the intended use so you could
imagine that thing pretty easily that
acceptance criteria for a genotyping
test versus a which you would use this
next generation sequencing or or PCR
would would be very different for in the
last eight its use to measure autoimmune
disease and some of the other examples
of different types of devices by the
technology intended use are listed below
so it's very difficult for us to define
acceptance criteria it depends really on
them the use would realize those the
population of patients that have been
tested and then the type of technology
that's being used this is just sort of a
simple example of decide get rid of that
looks pretty north at right now sorry
this is a simple example of two
different types of devices that I
mentioned the previous slide the first
one will be genotyping for factor eight
mutations in fact of 18 the other is
nearly last day that's used to measure
auto auto antibodies for detection of
lupus in this example and so you can see
the acceptance criteria if you just sort
of go down the chart are quite different
so particularly in the sensitivity
to sensitivity genotyping test the
acceptable acceptance acceptance
criteria for sensitivity 100% whereas
for us for auto antibodies these Royals
24-percent the study design is also very
different with the number of patients
that are required to perform these
studies as well as precision so you can
see that depending on the type of cast
in types of technology is being used the
acceptance criteria in the study design
can be very very different then it's
difficult a priority for for us to
define what the deception criteria can
be it should be before we understand
being the type of test who's the patient
population that it's going to be used in
and and more and also that the
technology that underlies the test some
of the surprisingly common mistakes that
we see it when people make submissions
for leisure Diagnostics we talked about
acceptance criteria sometimes
manufacturers will sex at subscribes
here and then when the data are analyzed
if they don't meet them this is
obviously a problem because because
they're dumb bleep acceptance criteria
cannot be used to to verify or validate
performance of the device another
important one is not performing the
analytical and clinical validation on
the final device so sometimes
manufacturers will change the device
after they've done their data data
collection and data analysis and it's
obviously the performance of the device
before its data bit that we receive has
to be done on the final device that
would ultimately cleared for for
approval and I'm not going to go through
a lot of these you can use some of the
other surprisingly common mistakes that
we that we see when people submit data
after a neutral diagnostic devices we've
talked about different types of
submissions mostly five contagion pnas
and and
also some very basic things about
intended uses and analytical and
clinical performance data were really
great database for people who are
interested in developing devices or
manufacturing devices is to 510 K
databases in the PMA databases that are
publicly available and this is just a
screenshot of an entry for the newborn
screening test using mass spectrometry
and what this arrow is pointing to here
it's basically a link to what's called
the decision summary which provides a
general overview of the data that was
submitted to to clear this device both
analytical and clinical performance data
and this database exist for there's an
entry like this exists for every clear
approved device that the FDA has clearly
free for the last since 1976 and it's an
excellent source of information for
people who want to manufacture is it a
dry spell because you want to develop a
and i believe it is similar to an
existing device you can look at the data
that was required to in this case clear
this you weren't reading test and then
the acceptance criteria netsetter so
it's a good publicly available source of
information about how i see it reduce
these types of city developed text
devices and the information from the day
that was used to clear clear market in
the united states so now going to talk
so that is sort of introduction to how
we here in CDRH think about you to
diagnostics some of the broad
descriptions and intended uses and some
of the common problems that at common
things very problems that we see that
people have when they submit their
devices I want to talk for the rest to
talk about specifically about mass spec
and our experience with mass
spectrometry in vitro diagnostic devices
there we do have some experience
clearing these devices and in this last
part apoplectic mentioned in the
introduction talk specifically about
protein and peptide mass back in
nuclear diagnostic devices so to start
with the mass spectrometer the
instrumentation itself in this evocative
of high-performance liquid
chromatography hplc s the insurance
themselves are what's called class one
events which means the low-risk devices
that do not require a formal submission
to the FDA but they do have to be
produced under good manufacturing
practice and also the manufacturers or
VHDL see Adam aspect must be registered
enlisted and there is also a database of
companies that are registered and listed
to to market a hplc and mass
spectrometers for use for clinical use
and that that database is publicly
available cuts on the FDA website the
important thing to keep in mind those
will even though the mass spectrometer
itself is class 1 event when the assay
is added on to the instrument then that
whole system the mass spec plus the
essay becomes classified as the risk of
the assay itself the adversity turned by
the essays so for instance you know a
test which is used to regulatory factor
but not feeling very high or the test
that is used to determine to as amazing
diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis will
be a class to that you if it use the
mass spec amendment the mass spec would
also the mass spec itself would also be
reviewed as a class 2 device and there
have to be a submission specifically
about the instrumentation I'm not going
to read this this is the definition of a
mass spectrometer according to the
statute it's in the Code of Federal
Regulations there's also one for high
performance liquid chromatography that
you can in search for on the on the
database the FDA website database so in
the last little more than 10 years the
FDA actually has cleared or approved
three different types of mass spec based
devices the first one
reliable discusses the device for to
measure inborn errors of metabolism for
newborn screening test this is a test
which is commonly done across the United
States there were several devices 33
different 510 caves which are listed
here which were basically describing
targeted mass spec assays for specific
metabolite amino acids and low molecular
weight substrates to identify inborn
errors of metabolism the other class the
second class is there food drug
monitoring there's been one 510 K which
has been cleared to monitor the union's
presence architect Cronus and again this
is an lcms based device and the third
one which was cleared more recently in
2012-2013 are devices which use maldita
protein profiling to identify for
identification of microorganisms that
are part of an active infection so just
a little bit to give you some idea of
the scope of the different technologies
and types of studies that we that
required for clearance of these devices
miss charts from outlines broadly you
know the hobby hace was defined the
procedure that's used to generate the
result as well as something analytical
factors that required for clearance the
devices the point of this slide is the
twofold want us to give you know an
overview and what these devices do and
second is to indicate that we have
experience here at the FDA with
regulating different technology
technologies whether it's also a master
multi and also use of mass spec for the
monitoring of different types of
analytes in other chemical in nature in
terms of monitoring or metabolites or or
even proteins in the case of the multi
talk device I'm not going to go through
this sliding a lot of detail you can
read some of the highlights there even
one of what I want to focus on is the
sum of the analytical factors that you
can see
quite different so we can start I think
with the mall detox on the right this is
a device which uses a colony and from
from the microorganism which is spotted
on a plate some of the important things
that were that were required to create a
device for understanding effective the
ages of colony the stability of the
colony on the plate what kind of culture
me it is used to developer copy em to
develop the samples for the spotting so
sort of very device specific and analyte
specific questions that need to be
addressed by the manufacturer of the
four clearance of this device the other
two devices were more similar in the
sense that they're they're obviously
enough devices that are used to 2mon to
quantify chemical compounds or or
metabolites for the newborn screening
assay an important component of it was
actually the sample prep so this is a
use a dried blood spot from a real stick
from firm instances are there was some
validation of the some sort of sample
collection reagents and both of them
also of course had analytical had
analysis of the linen jacket the
extraction efficiency the carryover
reproducibility etc so again just an
exhibited an overview three different
types of tests that have been cleared by
the FDA so far that use mass
spectrometry as the technology platform
for in vitro diagnostic so now i watch
the finish the talk and rather finish
this section about mass spectrometry in
particular talking about protein and
peptide mass spec which is in particular
interest to me i think that probably
many people on omnia who are pretending
this online know that there have been a
for the last fifteen and twenty there's
a large number of proteomic discover
experiments to try to identify
biomarkers that can be used as integer
diagnostics and this could be either
using mass spectrometry as the as the
technology platform or or antibody
arrays or other proteomic technologies
which are designed to quantify or
identify proteins on a large scale on
onyx scale unfortunately from none of
these discovery experiment seven on or
last 15 or 20 years have translated into
an FDA cleared pre-cleared or approved
in vitro diagnostic that uses mass
spectrometry is the technology platform
and there could be a number of reasons
for this the instrumentation is quite
complex and potentially difficult to
transform transfer into a clinical lab
the sample preparation is quite complex
which we'll talk about in more detail
but lately there have been efforts to
improve the reproducibility
electroactive the papers that have been
published in the literature spurts are
specifically looking at peptide and
protein so specifically using a peptide
mass spectrometry as an effort to try to
move peptide and protein mass spec
closer to clinical lab and there are
currently manufacturers and clinical
labs that are starting to offer an
aspect based assays at laboratory
developed tests to peruse in diagnosis
clinical diagnosis so one could ask why
is it that mass spectrometry has not
been very well adopted for peptide and
protein mass spectrometry and it's for
use in the clinic it is a widely used
platform for metabolites and chemical
compound to talk about you then
screaming in and took a drug monitoring
also used quite it's also used quite
often for drugs of abuse and that's
because it has many of you probably
online know that it has a very high kind
of a very high sensitivity good
precision I think one of the keys here
for mass spectrometry which is different
from other technologies we going to
multiplex
newborn screen is a good example wrapper
or more than 30 different compounds can
be analyzed from a single sample the
other nice thing about mass spectrometry
is that the the assays can RX or can be
constantly updated and optimized and
emily lasses can be developed rather
quickly once you know if you if the
clinical lab has expertise in
instrumentation in mass spectrometry so
the question is why is this not
translated more into peptide and protein
mass spectrometry and we believe that we
experience the decades of experience
that manufacturers in the FDA has with
clearance of amino acids as in vitro
diagnostics can be applied to peptide
and protein mass spec as I sort of
highlighted in there or discussed in the
very famous next slide so in many ways
we believe that mass spectrometry based
assays are just like every other
technology so in this case we make sure
think about a million elasa as a as a
similar type of vitro diagnostic to
measure a peptide or protein the
analytical validation which required is
the same whether you use an immunoassay
or mass spectrometry very precision
disability etc the things that we talked
about earlier clinical validation should
should not be any different the test
whether it's in the amino acid or a mass
spectrom space device has to demonstrate
effectiveness clinical effectiveness and
basically that you know the goals and
the data that are required to
demonstrate analytical and clinical
performance are no different for mass
effect on the mac for any other type of
device however as in Shermans you know
there are differences there are there
are other challenges that associated
with mass spectrometry based devices
quickly those that are not used to
measure peptides and proteins the sample
preparation can be quite complex so for
instance of serum or five example might
be
the most abundant proteins to try to
increase sensitivity for peptides of
course description digestion step which
can cause variability sorry about this
type of should save in your education
some tests that are being developed
certainly literature are either Amina
precipitating the protein before analog
analysis or interpret obtaining the
peptide that's being measured by mass
spectrometry and that creates a complex
workflow of it that is different from at
the amino acids that are typically used
to measure proteins the other things
sort of great advantage in mass
spectrometry is the building to
multiplex but this creates additional
complexities both analytically as well
as in the evaluation of the results if
for instance if the multiplex result is
meant to be combined if the individual
multiplex results are going to be
combined into a single score through an
algorithm that can create complexity is
not common in any last days but
certainly not something which were not
whether it certainly is something we're
used to dealing with and you've been
evaluating at the FDA and as I said
before one of the advantages of mass
spectrometry is the ability to develop
very quickly methods to measure novel
hemorrhoids so this is not as easy to do
with amino acids because of the lack of
available antibodies for one of the
challenges with developing many
different methods for many different
novel analyzes that there are not gold
standards of reference methods for
there's an alliance and that can create
analytical performance challenges for
for device developers device
manufacturers just to do a little bit
deeper into sample preparation and
sample in and sample and the instability
one of the things which is likely is
with a complex workflow that involves
generation of say peptides for a protein
it for a cup time aspect based assay the
sample collection the sample digestion
the sample cleanup etc
I can create a lot of variability and
then there was the most likely to need
to evaluate the the effective sample
preparation and multiple sites with
multiple users different multiple
instruments if it's an automated sample
preparation essay additionally because
these workflows are so complex instead
of taking you know 20 minutes to an hour
to complete the to get to get to the
result of the test as is the case with
many automated immunoassays the process
could take many many hours or perhaps
even several days to go from collection
to sample preparation and they're
probably maybe stopping points along the
way our samples lead to be stored and
the sample stability would need to be
evaluated into those stages to
understand how storage and preparation
over time is affecting the stability of
the analyte result of the test sighs did
not document ignore that arrow okay
we're going to the next slide the other
really important thing in our view in
terms of peptide and protein mass spec
in and this is also also applies to many
in the metabolites in and chemical
compound analysis using mass
spectrometry is the choice of use of
internal standards one of the great
advantages of mass spectrometry is the
ability to amuse a topically heavy
labeled internal standard which allows
for a very high level of specificity and
certainty that the analyte being
measured is the correct one as well as
the ability to normalize samples
normalizing a better sample in the
process sample to improve the
reducibility come the challenge is
further device developers and
manufacturers as well as the FDA is what
sort of the internal standard would be
used a peptide or a whole protein
what is it possible to use a
housekeeping protein there's a way to
normalize or perhaps especially in the
standard protein another question of
interest is when despite so ideally when
the spike at the very beginning before
any sample processing has happened that
may not be possible and then they're
also made me questions about monitoring
trypsinization and they send the a.m
reproducibility and the robustness of
traditions that might be several
standards that could be additive
different parts of the process don't
have any answers to these questions
right now if it really will depend on
the type of test them and the precision
reproducibility is required and and the
expected using these internal standards
at different points in their in the work
Florida to to make sure the test is
robust and has a good analytical
performance so another thing I've talked
about before is the is the fact that
mass spec assays are often multiplexer
can be multiplex and many device
manufacturers and developers are
interested in taking advantage of that
so there is we do have experienced at
the yesterday with that we call this an
IV be multivariate index assay or IBD
m.i.a which is basically measuring
several analyzing the same the same
assay a question will come up how much
evaluation of each individual feature is
needed in this case would say use the
measuring three different peptides two
different proteins we combine them into
an algorithm for example obviously with
any individual peak and some of those
multiple pieces of the variability of
the peaks is a concern I think probably
the most important part of your slide is
really the last bullet point here when
it comes when it comes to understanding
which peaks are most important and then
how much evaluation of each individual
features needed one their developer
manufacturer
should ask which features are key and
making a clinical decision so those are
the features that need to be understood
in the most detail from an analytical
performance and then of those features
that are teeming in clinical decision
which are most sensitive to the asset
conditions in which in which asset
conditions are most affecting the
variability in the detection and
quantitation of those Peaks so at the
point of sprite is to point out not only
these questions but also the good we
emphasize that this is something that we
are very familiar with in terms of
devices at the FDA and so a mass spec
based device that came in with measured
multiple analytes will be something that
we're very comfortable with evaluating
if an important point to make and I'm
won't go through all the bullets in this
slide but important point to make is
that any idea money that it takes the
result of each individual feature and
four-month internal rhythm is considered
the other than itself is considered a
medical device and there is a lot of
guidance available for how to be kind of
information that needs to be submitted
in terms of sausage contained in
medicine medical devices and so don't
have time to bring to a lot of this
detail here but recommend that people
review those guidance documents to
understand how algorithms are reviewed
and it just kind of dated in three
submitted so the last two parts of the
talks are about how you people can
interact with the FDA and how we
interact with the community so over the
last five years we've done quite a bit
of outreach in particular to the
proteomics community to help try to
build a clear and useful regulatory
pathway that the device developers
manufacturers can follow to submit a
mass spec based IBB we've been working
with the student
for sometimes like I said serve more
than five years and there's some
resources there at the end of the talk
within last speak Latin positive that
are available to help guide assay
development but the first thing I wanna
talk about is in 2010 there was a
workshop on the NIH and FDA and many
other many other people who look at the
analytical validation issues there
specific for multiplex proteomic
platforms and those mass spec base than
there was also an assuming based
platform this the results of this
workshop were published and there's the
reference you can see it right there one
of the things we really important things
that came out of that workshop was
something called a mock 510 K a further
collaboration between the FDA NIH and
several scientists to create what we
call the Mach 5 10 K on the one that's
most relevant to this discussion is a
mock 510 K describing a multiplex
multiple reaction monitoring mass spec
platform and basically and this law of
course was all was also publishing the
references are here but the bottom line
was that people were we work with the
NIH and FDA to submit a and describe a
device that measured multiple peptides
using Mr in the mass spec these were or
submitted to the FDA not officially sort
of cloud in quotes and the FDA made
comments on it and on the submission as
a way to try to help device developers
manufactures understand the kinds of
questions that yesterday would ask about
such a device and encourage you all to
to me the those papers somewhat typical
comments that came out of the submission
is mock laughs in case submission are
very I'm not going there always but
because started with freak when we found
on other types of submission so again
emphasizing the fact that
mass spec today's devices are not our in
many ways very very similar to other
devices in terms of the kind of
questions and inference that the FDA has
in terms of analytical and clinical
performance and finally about a year and
a half ago now jun 2014 my colleague
Julia Lathrop organized the public
workshops on premise in the clinic there
were many speakers it was a day-long
conference discussing the scientific and
regulatory challenges surrounding
validation and proteomic methodologies
including mass spectrometry and if
you're interested in looking reading a
transcript as well as seeing video of
all the presentations you can go to that
link to see what happened that the
public workshop in June 2014 so finally
I want to end in the last couple of
minutes talking about the pre-submission
process this is another way for device
developers and manufacturers to interact
with the FDA this is a formalized
process at crh the ideas that device
developers and manufacturers can contact
the FDA early and get feedback on the
types of devices that sort of technology
behind the device 3 and the analytical
and clinical testing that is being
proposed I think the key thing is is
it's free so anyone can submit
pre-submission for the fda to discuss
their in vitro diagnostic device another
key point is there's non-binding which
means that the fda is happy to provide
our advice and recommendations about how
a particular idg might be studies that
might be used to validate the corner
horn and local performance but the of
course it's not it's not meant to be a
an approval process so the approval
process has to be done through a formal
510 K or PM a submission so basically at
the FDA review team we'll look at the
device and spend quite a bit of time
look at the documentation about the best
friend quite a bit of time providing
feedback
to post specific questions perhaps no
general comments about the device and
how a device developer might think about
generating the doing studies and
generating the data for for a submission
and if you want more information about
the pre-submission process there's a
link here to the guidance document that
which gives quite a bit of information
about the process and how how it can be
used by device developers so in
conclusion the as I said at the
beginning the intended use of the device
is is the most critical parameter so
it's not as it meant to be screening or
diagnostic or mentor to God treatment
cetera and in which patients so the
antenna DC includes both how it's meant
to be used and also in the patient
population that that guides not only
that God's there the risk of device but
also the studies that are required to
show the clinical mental performance of
the device the one of the critical
things that we look at in the FDA is
what happens what's the risk of the my
scaling and so understanding of failure
modes of the different test systems will
will also direct the focus of clinical
analytical validations with testing that
needs to be done we are very interested
in mass spec based devices particularly
for peptides and proteins of course for
chemical molecules as chemical compounds
in the tablets as well but I focused on
the end about about peptide and protein
mass spec we were very interested in and
helping device developers and
manufacturers understand how to how to
bring those devices such a device to the
FDA but for clearance or approval and
finally you can talk to the FDA either
through the pre-submission process or
through our outreach efforts we easily
go to conferences around the United
States to to meet manufacturers and
device developers and talk to them
particular problem so if you have any
questions or comments about this talk
and happy to to a few bit we email or
call me and that's the end I want to
thank in particular for the stock my
colleagues Julia Lathrop and Stafford
who are in the division immunology
ontology devices and I will end there
excited one more thing they're here at
the end of the two slides some of the
references that I talked about for the
four fva guidance documents the Mach 5
10 k presentation as well as some Leslie
resources if they're specifically
related to mass spectrometry-based
prices so i'll leave the bear and happy
to answer any questions well thank you
dr. Jeffrey further informative
presentation I think we all learned a
little bit more about the FDA process
for devices it's time now for Q&A so if
you have a question that you'd like to
ask dr. Jeffrey please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type in your question and the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button will be will be happy to
answer as many questions as we have time
for so we'll give you guys a little bit
of time to put in your questions but in
the meantime I'd have a question my
ability to ask you dr. Jeffrey of your
mind so I'd like to know if you can
comment on the process by which the FDA
grants the expedited access pathway
status for a device and what that means
for the review process that's goodbye
that's an excellent question i i would
have to point you to the guidance
document i think it's very clear from
the vents document on the EIA expedited
access sr EAP the idea is that similar
to
the program in Cedar devices that are
for diseases that are sort of high unmet
need for for our other devices or other
devices don't exist already are
candidates for the EAP program and the
EAP program would would give a sort of
higher level of access to the device
manufacturing and more resources on the
FDA side to try to expedite the the
clearance or approval of such as rice
for marketing there are specific
criteria that have to be met by the by
the device manufacturer the terms of
type of device the intended use
population etc I don't have the I
obviously don't don't have a reference
on the slides to the guidance document
but if you go to UFC looks like there's
a guidance document for it be how to get
access how to apply for the EAP program
and the types of devices in the type of
information that's required to to apply
well thank you so much for that we have
another question that says if it's in
the same aspects I do more than one
essay it should be validated as a
different system with every new essay
sorry can you repeat the question yeah
so the question is it's in the same
aspect the person does more than one
essay should it be validated at the
different system with every new a thing
I think the question is if the if a an
instrument is cleared for one assay does
it then have to be cleared again for the
second assay and I think it's going to
really depend on the two different types
of assays they're being cleared so you
know the like we said each assay is
evaluated separately
in terms of its its risk whether it's a
class 1 and class 2 or class 3 so so for
example you know if a class 2a say were
cleared on a particular instrument and
then class 3 device was wanting to be
manufactured about the one to clear a
class 3 device on that same instrument
that would be a completely new
submission and with the issuer would
have to be evaluated in the context of
the class 3a say so really it really
depends on the the risk of the risk
classification of the assays that are
being there being used on particular
instrument system okay another person
asked if you could comment on the
patentability of math leg paint based
test unfortunately I cannot here at the
FDA we we don't look at or evaluate
patents in any way you know that's a
more of a business or scientific aspect
of device development it's not something
that we consider in any way okay mark
our money wants to know if there's a
difference between high resolution ms
and ms frosh IMS i'm not sure what the
MS / MS is ya know I I do so the
question is about the different types of
instrumentation that's available for
mass spec researchers and clinicians
using high-resolution instrumentation
such as perhaps a really good question
i'll just speculate that it might be
about to accuse active instrument versus
a standard triple quad that does tandem
mass spec and right now it's hard to say
particularly about the high resolution
mass spec i think that both the
community and the fda have a lot of
experience with
sort of a more standard triple quad and
SMS system and use for use in clinical
iBD's the high-resolution
instrumentation can be used obviously in
that mode in an SMS mode but it's not
commonly used so at this point it's hard
to say I don't think there's enough
information out there certainly not in
terms of ID be use to to highlight any
obvious differences between the two it
really is going to depend on again the
type of a say in energies population and
what whether the high-resolution data is
providing any information that sort of a
typical MSMS attend in the message
neutral club would not provide and what
the impact is that on the on the
clinical on the outcome of the test and
not ultimately the clinical decisions
being made so I think it at this point
in my opinions will too early to to be
able to say whether there any
significant differences between the two
I think it requires more more more
studies and more data from
high-resolution use of the
high-resolution mass spectrometers in
the clinical labs okay um Erin would
like to know and she says I thought that
LD pts are currently exempt for these
procedures based than on the proposed
guidelines so I would recommend so so
the the she's referring to the proposed
guidance that was developed by the FDA
for lab for regulation of Blandford
developed tests this talk has not meant
in any way to provide comment or
information about the regulation of LD
teams and but in fact yesterday there
was a discussion there was a talk given
by the FDA by dr. Catherine Serrano
about the current status of the
regulation of
Munford develop test or LTPS I can't
comment at all about that regulation and
this talk is not in mint in any way to
to provide more information about the
guidance of regulation of LDS but I I
highly recommend that you read the
proposed guidance as well as perhaps go
and listen to dr. Serrano's talk which
she gave as part of this lab roots
webinar on a fight yesterday okay great
and so while we have time for one more
question Fred Ethan asked what is the
FDA position on multivariate diagnostic
devices for example in this on triptych
digest of protein mixtures what is that
position our position it's a great
question and I mean certainly we
appreciate the power of multiplexing and
the fact that it's most easily done
using mass spectrometry our position is
that we we think it's a powerful
application of the technology we have
certainly have experience with multiplex
assays in other using other technologies
and we have methods we have processes in
place to evaluate such a device from so
we highly encourage people who are
developing multiplex assays to you know
to come in and either in the
pre-submission form or in a form of
submission and submit such devices we're
happy to to provide guidance mcfarling
pre-submission about how such a device
would be evaluated you know it's the
potential is tremendous so all I can say
is that we encourage people to you know
to to submit such a device and we're
happy to discuss how about a particular
device helps to your device will be
evaluated here at the FDA that's good to
hear
I would like again once again to thank
you for your presentation do you have
any final comments I I also thank thank
you for moderating and I thank lab roots
and for the folks that have been
participating online I hope that you've
learned something in general about the
the FDA process for regulation of in
vitro diagnostics and encourage all of
you who are interested in particularly
in mass spectrometry based devices to to
contact me or make a pre-submission
about your device were we're always
happy to talk about talk with
manufacturers and vice developers about
these types of devices and hope that we
can help work together to forge a
pathway for the regulation of these
devices in the future well thank you
once again much Jeffrey before we go I
wasn't everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
doing for six months from today's live
event which Thursday remember 12 2015
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
whom and this today's live events that's
also no thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye